nach dem tod eines afroamerikaners in
minneapolis proteste und gewalt reißen
nicht ab
trotz ausnahmezustands kompromiss zur
lufthansa rettung die airline soll start
und landerechte in frankfurt und münchen
abgeben
das grüne gewölbe in dresden öffnet
wieder ein halbes jahr nach dem
spektakulären einbruch dort
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und willkommen
bei den heute -nachrichten am samstag
vor pfingsten und wir schauen als erstes
in die usa wo die wut über den tod von
george floyd eskaliert der
afroamerikaner aus minneapolis war am
montag durch einen brutalen
polizeieinsatz ums leben gekommen gegen
den polizisten der minuten lang sein
knie in freuds nacken gedrückt hatte
wurde anklage erhoben unter anderem
wegen totschlags
vielen amerikanern reicht das aber nicht
wieder gingen sie in zahlreichen städten
auf die straße aus trauer und den
46-jährigen aus wut über die
abscheuliche tat
aus protest gegen rassismus und die
immer wiederkehrende gewalt gegen
schwarze und einige nutzten die
gelegenheiten gelegenheit auch für
plünderungen und brandstiftungen elmar
theveßen berichtet sie knien in
minneapolis signalisieren dass sie sich
ergeben so wie george floss hände nicht
schießen rufen sie in new york aber ihre
wut führt dann doch zu
auseinandersetzungen
die polizei beginnt mit den festnahmen
in dutzenden städten amerikas gehen die
sicherheitskräfte wie hier in phoenix
mit warnschüssen und tränengas gegen die
demonstranten vor es gibt verletzte auf
beiden seiten
die polizei bietet alles auf was sie hat
aber nicht einmal die nationalgarde kann
verhindern dass sich die gewalt wieder
bahn bricht in dieser nacht die
minneapolis brennt ist weiter die
demonstranten wissen dass der polizist
der george freund mit seinem knie die
luft nahm in haft ist angeklagt wegen
totschlags aber seine kollegen sind
weiter frei das reicht vielen nicht die
sinnlose gewalt trifft auch atlanta die
stadt von martin luther king
demonstranten greifen das gebäude von
cnn an mehrere polizisten werden
verletzt
die bürgermeisterin wendet sich mit
einem kraftvollen appell an die
krawallmacher
wenn ihr veränderung wollt geht wählen
ihr entwürdigt das leben von george
floyd und von jedem anderen der in
diesem land getötet wurde
der 12 jährige kathrin brian protestiert
so mit einem lied über seine angst vor
polizeibrutalität aber selbst vor dem
weißen haus in washington gibt es
handgemenge zwischen demonstranten und
dem secret service mitten in pandemie
und wirtschaftskrise nun auch noch
aufruhr in amerika präsident ram fordert
auf die armee in alarmbereitschaft zu
versetzen um das land wieder unter
kontrolle zu bringen elmar theveßen auf
mäßigende worte von ihm wartet die
bevölkerung offenbar vergeblich
ja ganz im gegenteil der präsident hat
ja über twitter eigentlich immer weiter
öl ins feuer gegossen hat auch gerade
noch einmal nachgelegt von wenigen
minuten am weißen haus hat er vor
reportern gesagt dass die radikale linke
der bürgermeister in minneapolis und
auch die demokraten die gouverneure
verantwortlich dafür sind dass die
unruhen so aus dem ruder laufen
erfordert mit aller härte gegen
demonstranten vorzugehen bietet die
armee an das kann er eigentlich gar
nicht die darf auf us-boden nicht aktiv
werden
aber es kann wohl ausrüstungs hilfe
geben für die polizei beispielsweise vor
ort und er hat seine anhänger aufgerufen
heute abend zu weißen haus zu kommen
falls da wieder demonstranten auch
herkommen könnte es dann heute abend zu
heftigen auseinandersetzungen zwischen
seinen anhängern und denen kommen die
eigentlich nur protestieren wollen gegen
die polizei brutalität
vielen dank für ihren bericht elmer nach
moshi jump hat nun auch seine drohung
wahrgemacht und die zusammenarbeit mit
der whu der weltgesundheitsbehörde
beendet damit verliert die whu einen
wichtigen geldgeber im zusammenhang mit
der korona pandemie wirft trump der
organisation vor
unter chinas einfluss zu stehen und die
welt zu spät vor dem virus gewarnt zu
haben
dabei hatte trump selber die gefahr
lange heruntergespielt
zu lange wie viele kritiker sagen im
tauziehen um das rettungspaket für die
lufthansa gibt es fortschritte
bundesregierung eu kommission und
konzernvorstand haben sich auf
bedingungen für die milliardenschwere
staatshilfe geeinigt
die lufthansa muss start und landerechte
an konkurrenten abgeben aber nicht so
viele wie von brüssel ursprünglich
gefordert susanne santina berichtet
viele flieger am boden und ohne
milliarden hilfe droht der größten
deutschen fluggesellschaft in den
nächsten wochen die pleite wohl deswegen
jetzt auch die verhandlungen des
vorstands bis tief in die nacht und am
ende das jahr zum rettungspaket das
sieht folgende auflagen vor
lufthansa muss künftig in den
heimatflughafen frankfurt und münchen
acht maschinen aus dem flugplan nehmen
sie verliert dadurch 24 start und
landerechte profitieren sollen
europäische wettbewerber lufthansa
wollte den beschluss nicht kommentieren
experten sehen keine alternative die
zeit drängt deswegen gibt es wirklich
nicht mehr viel spielraum wird lange zu
verhandeln unter den gegebenen umständen
glaube ich kommt lufthansa sehr
glimpflich davon denn die eu hatte
vorher weit größere einschränkungen für
lufthansa gefordert grundsätzlich sei
das wegen der neuen milliarden euro
hilfe notwendig man natürlich in einer
viel stärkeren position als die
mitbewerber
deswegen ist das wichtig und flughäfen
in denen viel los ist dass man
konkurrenz bekommt anders sieht das die
flugbegleitergewerkschaft ufo gegenüber
dem zdf
durch die staatshilfe sei es für
lufthansa überhaupt erst möglich zu
fliegen und die kreditschulden müssten
abbezahlt werden das mit einer noch
kleineren flotte machen zu müssen nützt
nur der billigkonkurrenz und gefährdet
tarifiert arbeitsplätze der druck auf
die kranich airline ist auf jeden fall
groß ihre milliarden reserven könnten
schon mitte juni aufgebraucht sein
dem deal müssen auch der aufsichtsrat
und eine außerordentliche
hauptversammlung zustimmen
die aktuelle entwicklung in deutschland
zeigt die zahl der neuinfektionen mit
dem corona virus ist leicht gestiegen
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich täglich 460 menschen
insgesamt registrierte die johns hopkins
universität stand 18 30 mehr als 183
1000 infizierte davon gelten mehr als
100 64.000 als genesen 8500 27 menschen
sind in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben
um weitere ansteckungen zu verhindern
bleibt das oberste gebot
abstand halten in göttingen haben diese
regel offenbar mehrere großfamilien
missachtet und gemeinsam gefeiert
die folge wieder ein größerer krone
ausbruch in niedersachsen
wie viele menschen sich an steckten ist
unklar
test ergebnisse stehen noch aus das
gesundheitsamt versucht unterdessen mehr
als 100 kontaktpersonen zu erreichen um
die infektionskette zu durchbrechen wie
zuverlässig sind corona tests
verschiedene studien zu dieser frage
haben wir online ausgewertet und mit
experten gesprochen
ein faktencheck mit vielen erklärungen
in der zdf- heute- app die korona krise
setzt der deutschen wirtschaft zu ein
wichtiger zweig der tourismus bayern ist
mit mehr als 40 millionen gästen eines
der beliebtesten reiseziele in
deutschland der umsatz im vergangenen
jahr rund 34 milliarden euro knapp
600.000 menschen arbeiten in der branche
und für die geht es jetzt wieder los
seit heute dürfen hotels ferienwohnungen
und campingplätze in bayern wieder
öffnen
patricia schäfer bayern darf wieder
urlaubsland seien die bergbahnen fahren
die schiffe steuern die ausflugsziele an
und auf der zugspitze geht alles außer
dem grenzübertritt nach österreich auch
die bayerischen schlösser bieten wieder
führungen an
wir haben die ganze zeit eigentlich
geschaut wann wir wieder raus können
wann es auf macht und heute erste tagen
direkt gefahren natürlich fühlt sich
anders an wenn man mit einer maske durch
schloss herrenchiemsee läuft aber im
großen und ganzen finde ich das alles
nicht so schlimm
die masken sind der preis der freiheit
auch auf den ausflugsdampfer und in den
innenräumen der hotels doch gäste- und
hoteliers sind froh dass es überhaupt
wieder losgeht auffallend ist dass die
unterkünfte sehr unterschiedlich
ausgelastet sind
die nachfrage bei ferienwohnungen ist
super groß also da sind wir eigentlich
für den rest des sommers ausgebucht
hotelzimmer noch sehr verhalten nur gut
die hälfte der zimmer seines hotels sind
belegt obwohl die bayerischen gastgeber
alle zimmer vermieten dürfen und
pfingsten eigentlich hochsaison
großer knackpunkt das innen puls und
saunen noch geschlossen bleiben
wir haben sehr viele gäste die dann die
zuerst gebucht haben dann wieder
storniert haben wirklich aufgrund dessen
weil sie gesagt haben auch der
wellnessbereich den darf ich nicht
nutzen die gäste die kommen genießen die
ruhe
doch profitabel für hoteliers und
seenschifffahrt ist das nicht chiemsee
ist ein beliebtes busreise ziele und die
busreisen finden im moment noch nicht
statt
und die fehlen uns natürlich extrem
insgesamt ist es ein ruhiger neustart in
die bayrische urlaubssaison der
erwartete ansturm auf die
touristenhochburgen ist an diesen eher
kühlen pfingstsamstag ausgeblieben
noch einmal in die usa nach new york das
ist bekanntlich die stadt die niemals
schläft doch dass gruner virus hat die
millionenmetropole verändert da wo vor
der pandemie das leben pulsierte trifft
man jetzt häufig auf leere straßen
die menschen haben angst der new york
gehört zu den städten die am härtesten
betroffen sind knapp 22.000 coroner tote
sind bislang zu beklagen
nun soll das öffentliche leben langsam
wieder hochgefahren werden
aus new york berichtet johannes hano
es ist acht uhr morgens orange in
manhattan new york city kaum menschen
auf der straße die bürohochhäusern
leergefegt wo sich sonst jeden morgen
hunderte auch tausende zu den
fahrstühlen drängen
gähnende leere zweieinhalb monate ist
die stadt im lockdown der bar soll jetzt
schrittweise ab 8 juni gelockert werden
so der groovende die öffnung bedeutet
aber nicht dass wir zu dem zurückkehren
was vorher war
im leben geht es nicht darum zurück zu
gehen sondern nach vorne zu schauen
es wird eine andere eine neue normalität
new york wird nicht mehr sein was es
einmal war
viele geschäfte und restaurants werden
wohl nie wieder öffnen touristen bleiben
weg die theater geschlossen manche
möglicherweise für immer
ob und wie schnell diese extrem dicht
besiedelte stadt wieder auf die beine
kommt wird davon abhängen wie sicher
sich die menschen in u-bahnen und bussen
fühlen werden erzählte uns jackie co sie
ist mitglied in der transport kommission
des bürgermeisters wir haben angst dass
die menschen aus der stadt ziehen
wir haben das schon einmal gesehen in
den 70ern als unser nahverkehr am boden
war
viele sind damals weggezogen haben als
grund den schlechten zustand unseres pnv
genannt der gouverneur hat masken tragen
zur pflicht gemacht in allen gebäuden
geschäften und im öffentlichen
nahverkehr
manche unternehmen wie die börse an der
wall street haben ihren mitarbeitern
aber schon verboten mit bus oder u-bahn
zur arbeit zu kommen
noch ist völlig unklar wie die neue
normalität hier in new york aussehen
wird ein ortsname und eine zahl sind zum
symbol im streit um den kohlestrom
geworden datteln 4
das steinkohlekraftwerk in
nordrhein-westfalen produziert von heute
an kommerziell strom
begleitet von protesten der
klimaschützer im gegenzug sollen ältere
kraftwerke abgeschaltet werden
datteln soll bis 2038 laufen dann wird
der energieträger kohle ausgemustert so
ist es im kohlekompromiss zwischen bund
und ländern vorgesehen
thomas münten berichtet auch 50
ehemalige bergleute in montur
demonstrieren heute gegen datteln 4
für sie ist es unverständlich dass sie
einen berg ans netz geht für das kohle
aus dem ausland her geholt werden muss
es geht gegen die klimapolitik und gegen
eine verminderung des co2 ausstoßes in
den nächsten jahren wir dürfen dieses
kraftwerk nicht am netz lassen wir leben
schon mitten in der klimakrise sie ist
grausame realität müssen jetzt raus aus
der kohle und wir werden dafür sorgen
dass dieses kohlekraftwerk abgeschaltet
wird
vor allem junge menschen haben den weg
nach dateien gefunden eine rote linie
ziehen sie am kanal immer mit abstand
markierung um die auflagen der polizei
zu erfüllen
die ist mit zahlreichen beamten vor ort
ich bin eher enttäuscht dass das land
nordrhein-westfalen meint dass wir uns
hier die gesamte polizei macht vor die
nase stellen muss der kampf gegen das
kraftwerk ist noch nicht vorbei davon
ist der bund für umwelt und naturschutz
überzeugt dieses kraftwerk hat keine
rechtskräftigen genehmigung der klagen
gegen den bebauungsplan gegen die
immissionsschutzrechtliche genehmigung
und gegen den hafenausbau nur eine
unserer klagen muss erfolgreich sein
dann muss dieses kraftwerk wieder
abgerissen werden dazu hat sich der
rechtsvorgänger von juniper eon im jahre
2007 verpflichtet betreiber juniper
spricht heute von einem historischen tag
man gehe davon aus dass die gerichte die
insgesamt sechs noch laufenden klagen
gegen darin vier abweisend nach juniper
plänen soll das werk bis 2038 laufen
gold bergkristall und diamanten als
barockes gesamtkunstwerk das ist das
grüne gewölbe in dresden ein halbes jahr
nach dem spektakulären einbruch ist die
schatzkammer von august dem starken nun
wieder geöffnet
besucher können auch den tatort des
juwelen diebstahl sehen von den räubern
gibt es allerdings immer noch keine
heiße spur genauso wenig wie von den
gestohlenen preziosen gegen vier
wachleute wird ermittelt vom dresdner
schloss stehen sie heute schlange um die
ersten im historischen grünen gewölbe zu
sein denn nur 70 besucher dürfen pro
stunde in den begehbaren tresor
wir freuen uns einfach um es diesen
diese schätze alle an zu sehen möchte
unbedingt sehen und die stadtführerin
hat uns gestern schon erklärt die
umstände des raubs und das finde ich
sehr spektakulär
und umso mehr bin ich jetzt neugierig
ein halbes jahr ist es jetzt her dass
die schatzkammer zum tatort wurde bei
dem einbruch im november nahmen die
täter zahlreiche schmuckstücke von
unschätzbarem wert mit liebe und
diebesgut sind bis heute verschwunden
in mehr sicherheit wurde nun viel
investiert pläne die weltweit beachtung
finden sollen alle museen weltweit ob in
moskau auf in new york oder in
niederlanden alle beschäftigen sich mit
dem thema sicherheit und dazu ist
austausch gegenseitiges lernen notwendig
und wir wollen damit auch einen großen
beitrag für andere museen weltweit
leisten
die bewusste vitrine leer und ein
zeugnis des juwelen diebstahl
vieles musste aufwändig vom feuerlösch
pulver gereinigt werden womit die täter
einst versuchten ihre spuren zu
verwischen
glanzstücke die nun an anderer stelle zu
bestaunen sind
die sehnsucht war einfach sehr sehr groß
und wir geben auch raum natürlich das zu
erzählen was was ihr widerfahren ist das
traumatische erlebnis das wird ja auch
mit vermittelt und das wird ein
intensiver moment der begegnung mit
unserem publikum werden
die dresdner haben mit der schatzkammer
des ehemaligen sachsen königs ein stück
ihrer identität zurückbekommen
zum sport in der fußball-bundesliga
holte auch heute wieder der ball in
corona modus die ergebnisse der
geisterspiele jetzt von michael ruhnke
frankfurt gewinnt am 29 spieltag in
wolfsburg mit 2 zu 1 mainz gegen
hoffenheim 0 zu 1 härter gegen augsburg
zwei zu null und die abstiegsbedrohten
bremer gewinnen bei schalke mit 1 0 und
holen so aus den letzten drei spielen
sieben punkte
bayern münchen spielt zurzeit gegen
düsseldorf die ersten bilder im free-tv
können sie von 23 uhr an im aktuellen
sportstudio sehen
gestern abend siegte leverkusen in
freiburg mit 1 0 und kletterte in der
tabelle damit vorerst auf platz drei
hinter bayern münchen und borussia
dortmund in der zweiten tabellenhälfte
verschafft sich eintritt frei
mit dem sieg in wolfsburg etwas luft
werder bremen zwar auf dem vorletzten
platz aber noch auf tuchfühlung zu
düsseldorf und mainz der kulturbetrieb
liegt brach viele künstler sind durch
die korona pandemie in not geraten
darauf will der star piano pianist igor
levit aufmerksam machen in dem er 20
stunden lang das stück vexations zu
deutsch quälereien von erik satie spielt
der stream im internet ein appell nicht
zu vergessen wie corona die
lebensentwürfe viele künstlerinnen und
künstler zerstört sagt levit
morgen wird es bewölkt es bleibt aber
eher trocken und danach stehen die
zeichen auf noch mehr sonne und wärme
mehr zum vergleich von katja honnefer
das war es von uns danke ihnen für ihr
interesse
claus kleber bringt sie im heute journal
um drei viertel 11 auf den neuesten
stand und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
auch wieder dabei sind um 19 uhr noch
einen entspannten abend für sie und
einen schönen feiertag
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
ist viel zu trocken das zeigt uns die
klimatische wasserbilanz des frühlings
sie gibt die differenz zwischen dem was
an regen gefallen ist und was verboten
verdunstet wurde in deutschland sind das
ungefähr 50 bis 250 liter regen pro
quadratmeter die fehlen mit einer
ausnahme hier am alpenrand jetzt nur
nachts fällt kein regen es ist meist nur
locker bewölkt und im südwesten sogar
klar in nieder- und den oberbayern
sinken die temperaturen auf 4 bis 3 grad
dort droht also noch einmal bodenfrost
deutlich milder bleibt die nacht an der
nordsee und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen an der ostseeküste
und in bayern meister 14 bis 16 grad
sonst werden 19 bis 23 grad erreicht von
der sonne bevorzugt sind morgen die
schlei die lübecker und die kieler bucht
und die niederburg vorpommerschen
ostseeküste richtung bin dann gehts
dichtere wolken bei einem gegenwind aus
nordöstlichen richtungen und bereits am
vormittag kann es im erzgebirge etwas
regnen nachmittags dann auch im
oberpfälzer und bayerischen wald und an
der donau deutlich freundlicher über das
im westen und richtig freundlich für uns
alle wird es dann am pfingstmontag bei
18 bis 27 grad so ähnlich geht es weiter
erst am donnerstag drohen gewitter
jüngsten